achieving a competitive and digital
Europe was at the top of the discussions
during the competitiveness council
ministers adopted conclusions to remove
unnecessary berries in the single market
and to enable a smooth and quick
transition to the digital age for the
sake of Europe's competitiveness so we
understand that we need to work hard and
remove the remaining barriers
particularly in goods and services and
to create a stable and predictable
business environment and we need to do
at most to complete the single market so
that it provides real benefits through
our consumers and businesses ministers
also outlined ways to create simpler and
better rules to facilitate investments
the purpose is to implement the proposed
315 billion euro investment plan for
Europe on the second day of the council
ministers looked into how research
innovation and the digital economy can
boost growth and competitiveness finally
they discussed how to speed up the
transition towards a data driven economy
it is fair to conclude from the today's
discussions that data intensive research
can become an important driver of
innovation and growth if the right
preconditions are in place